in his opening statement judge Kavanagh
accused Democrats of a conspiracy to
sabotage his nomination this whole
two-week effort has been a calculated
and orchestrated political hit fueled
with apparent pent-up anger about
President Trump and the 2016 election
fear that has been unfairly stoked about
my judicial record revenge on behalf of
the Clintons and millions of dollars in
money from outside left-wing opposition
groups with us now from Washington is
Killian Conway counselor to president
Trump good morning Kelly Ann good
morning John we've seen two sound bites
from Brett Kavanaugh this morning one
the anguish the personal anguish talking
about his daughter the second being that
very partisan shot at Democrats I want
to focus for a moment on that second
part how can Judge Cavanaugh sit on the
Supreme Court and call balls and strikes
and be an impartial member of the
Supreme Court with that kind of a
partisan shot judge Kavanagh has done
exactly that John for 12 years on the
second highest court in the country the
DC Circuit and as he also said in his
sworn testimony yesterday there's never
been a whiff of an allegation like this
all the time he's been in the court with
any number of dozens of female law
clerks and more importantly people have
never questioned his judicial
temperament and his decisions he's
authored 300 opinions these senators
yesterday could have talked about that
and said they were talking about a
paragraph in a high school yearbook so I
believe once he gets to the Supreme
Court he will call the balls and strikes
fairly what he was responding to
yesterday was two and a half weeks of a
political hit job where the Democrats on
the Senate Judiciary Committee treated
both he and dr. Ford very unfairly they
abused him and for for their own
purposes he had showed them respect and
deference in his original confirmation
hearing and they showed him ruination
and destruction in return the ruination
and destruction I hear you and the the
partisan message is quite clear but the
American Bar Association when Lindsey
Graham was reacting to the partisanship
he cited the American Bar Association he
called it the goal
standard so they took something
different away from this testimony
yesterday they've asked for a delay
until the FBI can investigate dr. Ford's
claims the president has the ability to
ask for that has since it's his nominee
will the president listen to the ABA
which Senator Graham called the gold
standard and have a delay here well the
president's listening to then-senator
Joe Biden in 1991 where he said anybody
thinks FBI makes conclusions doesn't
understand anything patience Kellyanne
just an investigation ask some questions
to tighten up some of these details but
we had that yesterday for the whole
country to see and I think that your
reporting from your colleague ed is very
instructive here in that the sex crimes
prosecutor whom the Republicans asked to
come in and do the questions for dr.
Ford respectfully and and patiently that
she would never have enough evidence in
a court of law to prosecute the FBI has
conducted six vets six successful
vetting zuv Brett Kavanaugh throughout
his career he's raised his right hand
many times taking oath to the
Constitution swearing to uphold the law
and the most recent vetting of Brett
Kavanaugh occurred this summer
contemporaneously with the with the
letter that dr. Ford apparently sent to
the Democrats asking for anonymity so
that vetting result is on the desk of
every Democratic senator they ought to
open up and look at it because they're
not going to find anything there that
would cast doubt except for the most
hardened partisan against Judge
Cavanaugh's nomination look she didn't
provide corroborating evidence yesterday
in her testimony but he provided the
country corroborating evidence as to his
qualifications and temperament to be on
the Supreme Court well let's talk about
her for a second Kelly Ann Christine
lousy Ford what's your take on her
testimony was she credible to you
she was very compelling and I think very
sympathetic and I have said all along
including on your network Gail something
that Judge Cavanaugh said yesterday
under oath and I have goosebumps right
now it seems that she absolutely was
wronged by somebody that she was
sexually assaulted as judge Kavanagh
said at some point somewhere by someone
and that he and the rest of us mean her
no ill will I also have a ten-year-old
or two like he does and it's becoming a
little
it hairy in the way that we have to
describe these things to to our
youngsters but he wasn't there I've said
from the beginning it may turn out that
they're both right that she was sexually
assaulted but that he had nothing to do
with it and I think America saw that
yesterday I don't know why also that we
have to look at every woman
automatically as a victim if you're a
woman every man is a bad perpetrator
when did this happen that we line up
according to political lines according
to gender lines
I think yesterday's yesterday's hearing
if it had to happen was very elucidating
for the country but it never had to have
happened I think that everybody now will
recognize dr. Ford her life will be
forever changed
judge Kavanagh has said that his his
reputation he needs to restore it his
good family that the vicious threats and
death threats against his wife and
children and family so I feel like this
was mishandled by the Democrats from the
beginning who could have been asking
Judge Kavanaugh and and dr. Ford
questions in a much less public setting
it sounds like dr. Ford would have been
open to that yes a lot of people have a
lot of questions about yesterday was
certainly very partisan and very
riveting to watch and I'll say that and
I'm glad we the public had a chance to
see at Gaelic inerrancy is important
thank you
thank you very much Kellyanne for
joining us this morning